[Music]
as long as people have been alive
they've wanted to stay alive and for
centuries explorers have searched for
the fountain of youth and today
scientists are hard at work researching
technology that can extend the human
lifespan stop a reverse aging and even
preserve a terminally ill person
indefinitely until a cure for their
disease is discovered but what if
instead of preserving our bodies we
could preserve our consciousness by
uploading it to a powerful computer this
is called mind uploading and one startup
has developed a procedure to do exactly
this it's scientifically sound there's a
waiting list to participate and the
procedure
is 100 fatal
let's find out why
[Music]
there is no limit to human desire
unfortunately or fortunately depending
on your perspective there is a limit to
our lifespan
what if we could upload our memories
experiences or entire consciousness to
the cloud this would be a sort of
digital immortality and it might not be
as far-fetched as you think famous
futurist ray kurzweil believes we'll be
able to upload our entire minds to
computers by 2045 and by the end of the
century our entire bodies will be
replaced by machines now this might be a
bit optimistic but it really is just a
matter of time but there are a few
issues we need to solve first the
concept of uploading an entire human
brain is called whole brain emulation
and there are three main areas of
technology that make this possible
scanning processing power and
environment let's start with brain
scanning the complete map of the brain
is called the connectome and mapping
this is the holy grail and so far we've
only been able to map the complete
connectome of one creature
the nematode and the nematode brain has
about 300 neurons that doesn't sound so
odd well the human brain has over 80
billion neurons oh right but i guess a
heckle fish brain has even more neurons
in it well
and our 80 billion neurons are connected
by about 100 trillion synapses then you
have neurotransmitters proteins hormones
and all kinds of electrochemical
processes to replicate now all of this
needs to be mapped and understood before
we can even consider uploading now our
current imaging technology just isn't
good enough to map this out there are
methods that are better like cutting the
brain into millions of slices and then
using an electron microscope to scan all
the cells and synapses but this
technique is destructive we know that it
works though because this was done with
mice in 2019 a cubic millimeter of a
mouse brain a cubic millimeter of a
mouse brain was successfully mapped
using this technique now cubic
millimeter is only the size of a grain
of sand but this piece of brain contain
100 000 neurons and over a billion
synapses but this brings us to the
second problem with mind uploading
processing power and storage space when
that tiny piece of mouse brain tissue
was imaged it used about two petabytes
of data storage that's two
million gigabytes now okay fine that's
doable but for an entire human brain
we'd need 2 million petabytes or 2 000
exabytes that's a lot of storage for
comparison all of google storage
all of it is estimated to be about 15
exabytes so humid brain would need over
100 times what google has that's a lot
it is and let's say you cut a deal with
google to give you 2 000 x bytes of
storage what would they bill you for
this
well google says its biggest corporate
clients pay a little over five million
dollars per month per exabyte so the
cost to store a human brain 10 billion
dollars per month per brain hey uh can i
borrow your amex here's a little more
perspective on 2000 exabytes also known
as two zettabytes if you had a nickel
for every bite and stack them up the
pile would reach to the nearest star to
the earth alpha centauri that's flaw
and back whoa
100 times
what yup the stack of coins would be
2500 light years tall
i
can't can't comprehend i know but you
get the point a human brain and the
heckle fish brain is a ton of data and
that's just storage to actually process
this data would take more computing
power that's available on the entire
planet
but moore's law states that computing
power doubles every 18 months now this
is slowing down a little bit but it's
pretty much held true for years so this
means that even though we can't do it
now at some point in the future we will
be able to store this data and process
it and that's why mit graduate robert
mcintyre founded nectome a company that
claims to be able to back up your brain
and for a fee you can put yourself on
their waiting list to have your brain
imaged and stored in the cloud the only
catch is
you need to die first no such thing as a
free lunch nope
brain storage is not a new concept the
alcor life extension foundation has more
than 150 bodies
and severed heads stored in liquid
nitrogen but there's some dispute as to
whether liquid nitrogen damages brain
tissue so a few years ago robert
mcintyre while working with a
cryobiologist came up with a different
approach
their technique combines typical
cryonics with embalming to preserve the
brain structure nectome developed
aldehyde stabilized cryopreservation or
asc and nectome says their technology
can preserve a detailed brain
ultrastructure over long time scales
we're talking hundreds or even thousands
of years and their technique has proved
effective at preserving an entire brain
at nanometer level including the entire
connectome so all cells synapses fibers
proteins molecules all of it and there's
no expectation of reviving the preserved
tissue like with alcor life's cryonics
instead the idea is to retrieve the
information that's stored on the brain
anatomy now ken hayworth a
neuroscientist and president of the
brain preservation foundation said if
the brain is dead it's like the computer
is off but that doesn't mean the
information isn't there
that's really interesting will you sign
up for it well if you put down a 10 000
deposit you can get on the waiting list
but there's a bit of a catch you need to
still be alive at the beginning of the
procedure and at the end of the
procedure you won't be and that's okay
your body's gone but your consciousness
lives on but when you wake up
what's that like
uploading your mind gives you functional
immortality it means that you continue
to exist until your mind's digital copy
is deleted or destroyed you better hope
your brain doesn't run on windows 10.
well that's a pretty good point
[Music]
what happens if your digital mind
becomes corrupted hacked or infected
with malware that experience might leave
you with feelings of pain paranoia and
psychosis that could last forever but
let's assume everything goes according
to plan what does your digital
consciousness do
where does it go well one option is to
have yourself downloaded into a physical
body and that could be organic or
cybernetic but probably would be
something completely mechanical you
become a robot
well sort of a robot is defined as a
mechanism designed with human-like
features or to mimic human behavior you
would be more than that you would be a
conscious sentient being inhabiting a
mechanical form now assuming the
technology is there you would be able to
taste ice cream smell flowers have sex
fall in love all like humans do but
you'd be able to do these things forever
another option for your digital
afterlife is to inhabit a simulation by
inserting your consciousness into an
elaborate program you'd be able to
create and live in any type of world you
can imagine
kind of like a god you'd be able to walk
with dinosaurs or visit other planets
you could explore outer reaches of the
galaxy or investigate molecules in inner
space by adjusting your programming you
could delete painful memories and relive
positive experiences in an infinite
number of ways you could create a
perfect utopia and if you don't like
something in your simulation change it
and after hundreds thousands or even
millions of years you may have seen and
experienced everything you could
possibly imagine and at that time you
might choose to finally rest and turn
off your program altogether
but would you when we get to the point
where our minds could be converted into
a conscious sentient program we'll have
security in knowing that if we become
injured or ill that we can continue to
exist in digital form
but would we still be human
i don't know that's a question for
philosophers but i do know that because
our time here is so short that creates
urgency urgency to experience all we can
while we can that's why there's the
concept of a bucket list the urgency
makes us human if we could live forever
and experience literally everything what
happens
after that
what purpose would we serve and what's
our reason for even existing and after a
while would we even want to
now digital immortality isn't happening
anytime soon so go out and enjoy actual
life while you can
and the simulation without risk will
never be as exciting or as fun as the
real thing anyway we just have to accept
that we're not meant to live forever and
that's okay
but it'd be nice to have the option
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is aj that's hecklefish
this has been the y-files if you had fun
or learned anything do me a favor and
like subscribe comment and share the
youtube algorithm is like an evil
sentient digital consciousness bent on
our destruction but with your help we
can defeat it until next time be safe be
kind and know that you are appreciated
[Music]
you